the average quarterback faced a places--
from the Bengals Carson Palmer faced a
blistering Bengals the average
quarterback completed four passes of
those a places' Carson Palmer completed
six so then we go back and say okay well
you know let's just say that by
preparing its driver it helped you in
these two plays in the game so let's go
back and figure out where these two
plays critical plays that extend it
drives the ledges for us and they both
work it's a tight game came down to fuel
at the end it's little little things
this type of thing is not going to help
you complete a hundred percent your
passes but can it help you in the one or
two critical junctures in game that's
going to change the outcome of the game
and when you change the outcome one game
does it change the outcome of the season
that's kind of how we're thinking about
this stuff and what makes it exciting
you
the thing about this is really cool it
makes it different from just a connects
game or experience as we actually filmed
Rangers hockey players ripping shots at
the goal it's oh it's real video of real
players who are taking shots at you the
puck then becomes CG once it comes off
their stick so that's what enables you
to interact with it and you know block
it or miss it but it's this real video
overlay you're kind of sitting there
like you're going to get out of this
thing and you're gonna be sweaty and
you're gonna be feeling like you just
we're out of ice and so it's that
combination of real video on top of CG
that just makes it it's awesome
it's really cool